foreign
let's go out to Dana in Salt Lake City
what's up Dan and the Utes how we doing
well thank you how are you I'm dude
we're just having a party having a party
great so what's up how can I help okay I
am hey Dana do me a favor talk directly
into your phone for me okay
okay all right can you hear me better
yes a little bit better there you go go
for it
grandmother I've been divorced
three times I've had several
relationships since my last divorce
that have not worked out
um
I cannot keep even friends although my
children I have five children I get
along great with them their adult
children uh my grandchildren I get along
with great it's the personal
relationships that I have with
uh marriages
um with by uh trying to find the right
man I don't know if
if I am the narcissist
um I don't believe that I am but I am
afraid I might be I I cannot keep even
friendships
I am sad that
I can't do that right now but I've been
trying to get back with even my best
friend that I've had for years that does
not want anything to do with me
what's been the Catalyst for number one
thank you for your vulnerability like
what you're saying is hard to say out
loud right
um when we get married
we at some level deep in our bones say
this is forever and you said that three
times
and yes we think that good grief when we
were 12 or we were no before that we
were four we could barely remember to go
to the bathroom but we can always have
friends and then when we're adults we
there's an extra sense of Shame and what
a loser right so it's a bold Brave step
to say that out loud so I'm proud of you
I'm proud of you for saying Out Loud
Let's go uh let's let's divide these up
what happened in your marriages if if
you were to look at all three of them
and say Here's a common denominator
across all three what would that be
um
common denominator would be
me as a
so I've always figured it's it's me I
had to kind of look and say you know
yeah it's me so what is the issue I
think that it is
when things start going wrong
and I try to voice my opinion or I say
something but if I don't agree with you
um I get so upset why why what what
happened in your life that made you
circle the wagons on this idea that if
you're wrong you're worthless
I don't know it came from somewhere
I know it had to have been I had a great
childhood
so I I don't know
I uh I the only thing is my child
because I could remember I came from a
very religious family I wanted out of
the house fast because I did not want
want that lifestyle hold on I'm gonna
stop you right there you did not have a
great childhood then
because yeah
I I often take other Ops the opposite
call how do I get my kid out of here and
to quote my friend Dr Henry Cloud I've
got to often teach parents how to give
their kids problems like rent and bills
because their house is their life is so
great at home that they don't want to
leave both relationally and with needs
being met yours was the opposite you
couldn't wait to go
correct so carrying around this
narrative that everything was great and
wonderful and Grand is not true
somewhere along the way being wrong
was dangerous
somewhere along the way somebody took
away your
um Power and what I mean by that is
um it could be as simple as you didn't
want to hug every one of those uncles
and you had to line up and hug them all
and they'd kiss you on the mouth and on
the ear when you were a little girl and
you didn't want to and you squirmed and
you tightened up your body and you got
in trouble for it not them
and you learned at a young age that what
you want does not matter
what matters is that Mom and Dad look
good in this little system that we're in
and Dan I'm just making this up am I
close or not
you're very close I I rebelled at a very
young age just to
yeah
and often we we look at oh man
we look at children especially younger
children that quote unquote Rebel and we
want to beat them down and blame them
instead of looking at their little
bodies that are not developed yet and
say what about this system that we have
dropped this child into
is so sick that this child's body is
saying get out get out get out get out
get out
well and now you're 63. and for 35 years
you're willing to lose it all
for being right
correct for quote unquote winning
congratulations you see what I'm saying
yes yes
it's not working for me no there you go
there you go
um
I think the fact that you're asking this
question would suggest
um just off the top that you're not a
narcissist but let's run down the list
just for fun do you believe the world is
was just like was designed for you that
ultimately people you are mostly smarter
than everybody that you are around
you're probably more or less more
beautiful than other people
um one day you're going to be more
successful than everybody around you is
that is that how you see the world
no
do people in the world exist for your
pleasure
no
what are you entitled to
besides being right
nothing really I can't
do entitlements seriously yeah let me
ask you this when when you when one of
your husbands was to say
we're not making out enough
and you felt that rage I I call it that
inner thermometer just shoots up right
and it explodes out the top
and you point at him and say how dare
you we make out all the time and this
and this and this
yes do you feel like he was stupider
than you or do you feel like he was
being honest and you were having to
defend yourself
we're
what's the picking on me like they were
trying to
yeah but it was it was me here you're
you're bad you're you're not doing this
you're not doing that you're not giving
me what I need so here I am so then I
feel like I have to defend myself
and I
um so the the
your body has some pretty simplistic
just pretty simple responses to trauma
correct it'll run
it'll turn and pick up a stick and fight
and it's it's amazing I've got a
gigantic 13 year old son who's very very
strong we wrestle we got we got
wrestling mats upstairs we wrestle he's
very strong but when it comes down to
like confrontation
yes his natural inclination he's very
very very fast he'll take off
he leans away my seven-year-old daughter
who's
0.3 pounds I could sneeze and knock her
over
if we get sideways she squares up and
gets ready to throw down
so there's nothing about gender there's
nothing about strength there's nothing
about size it's just how bodies respond
and for some reason
your body
um responds to somebody challenging you
as an act of War
I said I could beat him up with my mouth
and what I want to ask you is what is
that got you
enough it's it's gotten me
to divorce I it's are you done with it
I am so done with it I'm in a
relationship now and trying so hard to
make this work okay I'm gonna tell you
right now you're you're already doomed
to fail again
oh here's why here's why
you're trying to constrict it even
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter until it
snaps
oh wow what I want you to do is to open
your hands completely and just freaking
let go Dana
let go
the more you have tried over the course
of your life to not screw something up
the Tighter and Tighter it has become
and then when he inevitably says
something that's going to be of
Confrontation why do you put the trash
in did you not did you not get this
thing why didn't you pick me up when you
said you were going to be there
is no margin it just goes bam it snaps
it's over I'm out bye
yep
that's it so let's do the exact opposite
here's what I mean
when you feel your body setting off
again and you've done this long enough
now and actually you are super just so
you know you are 20 counseling sessions
down the road have you been to therapy
before
yes okay you're you're way down the road
which is impressive it's really
incredible
so I want to tell you you're right at
the door here okay I want you to carry
around a little journal with you
okay and don't even use your notes app
because I want you to take the time the
kinetic time to write this thing down
okay all right and when you feel your
body starting to set off I want you to
hold your breath
hold it
for one two three seconds and remember
that knucklehead on some podcast you
talked to one day
okay
okay and all I want you to do is to look
at the person you're about to explode on
and say I need three minutes I need five
minutes
and then I want you to walk outside and
I want you to write down what you are
about to say to that person write it
down in your Journal
okay
is that cool
hey cool yes and next anytime y'all are
about to get into a discussion
I want you to about a thing whatever the
thing is I want you all to sit on the
same side of the table
and take a little note card and put in
the middle of the table thing that we're
talking about
that way all the energy and frustration
and rage and anger all those things that
come up are going to go to this thing
not to you and not to hit back to him
remember this in your soul
if you win and he loses you both lose
oh wow that's
awesome okay yeah that's oh great and he
wins and you lose you both lose
right so the goal here is to what what
is the thing that is going to push our
relationship a little bit further down
the road just just a couple of inches
and then a couple inches beyond that and
then a couple inches beyond that
right yeah right
wow hey here's your new identity okay
okay I want you to say these words out
loud
I'm Dana and I no longer go to no let's
let's don't even do that
I'm Dana and I'm a person who seeks
peace
I'm Dana I'm a person who seeks peace
I'm Dana I don't fight anymore
I'm Dana
more I'm Dana and I will love you till
the end of time
I'm Dana and I will love you till the
end of time
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to work in service of those three
identities we're just gonna work
backwards on it what do I have to do way
Upstream so that I can love you till the
end of time that means I gotta like when
you are with this person say it's pretty
obvious that I can uh like I I have a
hurricane inside of me that can be
Unleashed on from time to time and so I
want to try to do something different
now that I'm 63
yeah when I feel the hurricane coming I
want to step away so I want you to know
that I love you I'm in I like dating you
and I want to protect you and this
relationship and myself and so sometimes
I'm gonna say I need five minutes
to put to some more on uh podcaster told
me I need five minutes and then I'm
gonna write it down and then I'm gonna
come back in and I might write something
down on a note card and put it in the
middle of our table and you're gonna
think you're dating a crazy person but
we are getting on the road to being well
because I'm not fighting anymore
I'm seeking peace
I'm seeking peace and I'm gonna seek
peace in relationship
I
I've got high hopes for you Dana if you
commit I'm never going to war again I'm
done going to war and once I take War
off the table once I take rage off the
table once I take walking away off the
table once I take indignation off the
table
then it leaves only this many other
options like discussions and
communication and I need to go for a
walk and let's go talk to a counselor
about this let's call my sister in
because she can actually hear me or
maybe you call your friends and you say
I'm so sorry
I treated you like the demons that have
been Hound in me since I was a little
girl and I'm sorry
give me another shot
63 years old it's never too late to turn
it all around I'm so grateful for you
Dana keep me updated on your journey